not only is the Predator fighting wolver
rain in this comic he's also going to
fight the X-Men so picking up out of the
conclusion of the last video that we did
which took place in Japan we actually
don't stay here very long a lot of this
is because of the fact that wolver rain
was training with muramasa at the time
the guy who would go on to develop the
muramasa blade the only sword capable of
nullifying Wolverine's healing factor
and legitimately killing him again
because that wasn't the end of the story
Wolverine kind of fought the predator
for a moment or two but then like the
hands show up right like the mystical
ninja organization from Japan and the
Predator basically Bales now one of the
things to know here and this is one of
the things that Wolverine kind of talks
about for a second is he talks about the
idea that when it came to the Predator
he was hunting Wolverine exclusively but
the goal of the Predator was to also
figure out everything that was going on
around Wolverine and we'll talk about
that here in a second because what it
does is it picks up at Westchester and
the Xavier school for gifted youngsters
now in the the aftermath of everything
that's happened which is to say the
battles between Wolverine and the
Predator himself that he remembers
because one of the things that keep in
mind is that when Wolverine was part of
weapon x his memories were always being
altered and scrambled and so on so he
didn't fully recall the first fight he
had with Predator but what he does is
with all of this he just does a bunch of
patrols around Westchester the Xavier
school and he's always on the hunt
looking for predator to see whether or
not it's tracked him down now the kicker
about all this is nobody else seems to
know about this thing because Xavier
kind of comments on the fact that hey
you know like the kids miss you right
Kitty pride is always looking at your
chair wondering where you are
Nightcrawler does the same thing even
the kids themselves who are here are
like why isn't Wolverine ever joining us
for dinner but Wolverine ever the guy
who is just highly alert for any
Potential Threat out there is still
lingering and kind of holding on to this
ideology that he had in the early days
when he first joined the X-Men which was
that he shouldn't be there because
there's too many people that are always
following him always trying to take him
out and by associating with the X-Men it
puts them in danger but because Xavier
seems a little dismissive of it suddenly
the three dots from the Predator's
shoulder Cannon appear on this guy's
head basically it looks like Predator is
about to help Professor X finish with
all his living and in fact he almost
does right like he just fires off a shot
into the Xavier Institute Xavier saved
wolver rain in like the nick of time the
is basically unconscious so presumably
he can't use his powers to shut down the
mind of the predator and then just like
missiles come flying out of nowhere it's
a full-on frontal assault on the X-Men
mansion now Colossus shows up and
Colossus is like what in the world's
going on Wolverine doesn't spill the
beans he's just like get Xavier get him
to safety get him out of here as fast as
you possibly can the missiles went to
the upper floors that's where all the
students are going to be right so once
he gets up there he tells all the kids
get out of here go to some place safe
right like head downstairs losses will
help get you to safety he finds Kitty
Pride but then like the Predator shows
up just in time to like wrap wolver rain
and one of his cords electrocute the
piss out of him and leave him
momentarily unconscious now the funny
thing about this is that he kind of
starts to come to pretty fast right when
Nightcrawler shows up and Nightcrawler's
ability to teleport man it gets cool
here in a minute it gets really cool
here in a minute right like literally
Wolverine tells him like get out of here
right Nightcrawler teleports Wolverine
away and it's only a momentary bit of
safety because remember the Predator can
find heat signatures right so it's not
that difficult for him to just kind of
look around assuming their location is
within viewing distance of the Predator
itself and for him to hone in on exactly
where they're at and so of course at
that moment Wolverine just kind of lets
everybody have it to a degree and while
they're all pissed off at him about all
this he's just like no right you guys
have to stay out of this this is
strictly me he just like leaves the
problem here is that when he finds
Predator which you can can do because of
course Wolverine tracks Things based on
their scent and once he picks up a scent
he never loses it that once he finds
Predator it's got Rogue captive now a
lot of you guys are probably asking why
does Rogue look like this Rogue was
drawn this way because this takes place
seemingly shortly after Avengers annual
number 10 if my memory serves me
correctly which was the first appearance
of Rogan Marvel Comics it was actually
written by Chris Claremont who was
writing the X-Men at that point in time
and then she was rolled over into the
X-Men Comics pretty quickly but the
thing about this is that Predator just
kind of has her held as a hostage now in
response to this realizing that like
Predator will kill Rogue without a
moment's hesitation right because at the
end of the day this Predator is really
after Wolverine on such a level that the
normal honorable path what just to say
that Predators only attack those beings
that have weapons drawn on them and
present a clear and present danger that
that goes out the window right it's like
I'll do whatever I have to do in order
to get to you right so it is kind of
cool but Wolverine basically throw
throws a set of handcuffs on the ground
right those power dampening cuffs or at
least cuffs that allow him to be
contained and in turn leaves with The
Predator now when that happens like what
you end up finding out is this is not
actually Wolverine right instead
Wolverine comes running out of nowhere
now it's not Mystique right it is not
Mystique at all instead it actually
turns out to be Danny Moonstar which is
kind of cool right like the ability to
use magic and a change of physical
appearance and so at that moment
Nightcrawler teleports in right and just
like literally pulls the oxygen masks or
at least the air mass off the Predator
helmet and then like kitty Pride shows
up phases from the ground and then like
Knocks The Predator into the ground and
so at that moment like the Predator
ultimately ends up using his cloaking
ability to effectively leave and the
X-Men allow him to do that because the
X-Men don't normally kill unless they
absolutely have to so it kind of gives
the Predator a momentary repri and
that's when we jump to this fight in the
modern era because wolfang comes to the
realization and he even says it he says
I stake the helmet in the meadow like a
bait station next to a deer stand I
waited a week and then he came he would
never stop coming until my head was his
that's what all this right the attack on
the X-Men was designed to show wolverine
that the Predator was fixing out and
kind of understanding what his strengths
and weaknesses were learning what it was
that was the most important to him
because that's what any real Hunter does
and so he said of course he knew it was
an ambush I was counting on that I set
up an obvious rudimentary trap just
enough to give him some sense of danger
and confidence in avoiding it I needed
to get hit I needed my blood on the
ground because once he got a taste of it
and once he got a hold of that helmet
he'd think he'd already won and that was
the cool thing is because wolver rain is
actually playing the Predator while the
Predator believes he's playing wolver
rain and so that's when the Predator
Gets a shot off on wolver rain and like
blows his shoulder apart right and he's
just kind of like okay right like that's
when he starts to get a full
understanding of what it is that he's
dealing with now up to this point in
time the Predator didn't have the helmet
at his disposal and even Wolverine kind
of comments on that right he's kind of
like I suppose I could have just rigged
the helmet right poison the air filter
or put a bomb inside of it and he says
but over and over again Tech techology
has been the Predator's failing he
surrounded himself with it just like he
surrounded himself with trophies like a
boast or compensating for something to
feel right about taking him down I
needed to prove that I was deadlier than
the death he wore and so even where his
shoulders blown to pieces and it's
currently healing and he knows that he's
the hunted he knows that he's the prey
the Predator is using his helmet to
figure out his body heat one of the
things that Wolverine picks up on
relatively fast is that the Predator
uses body heat in order to track its
prey now this is something that he even
comments on later on down the line but
he only really says I fought the
Predator long enough to know that's what
he does so we don't know if that's
something that Wolverine picked up on in
their very early fights we don't know if
that's something that Wolverine is only
figuring out now because he's actually
involved in a one-on-one fight with the
predator and no distractions it gives
him time to think time to focus and time
to understand exactly what's going on
here we're not really given a definitive
answer and even then we don't
necessarily need it right but in this
moment when like the Predators hunting
him and blasts him right just like
shoots at him with a shoulder Cannon
wolver rain is just kind of dodging for
his life right like bobbing and weaving
it is kind of funny and it is an
interesting caveat because again all
this is feeding into the Trap that he's
creating lulling the Predator into a
false sense of security because
Wolverine can heal from anything I mean
we literally saw that in Civil War when
his whole body was blown apart by Nitro
the second time around and he just like
healed from his adamantium skeleton so
like the guy can heal from pretty much
anything right and he knows that and so
it is kind of cool to watch this happen
because he really talks about how he's
losing a lot of blood he says that makes
me slow to run and easy to track and he
says when I come to the cliff every
nerve in my body is firing a red alert
way down below is a river but right
behind me comes a watery Ripple and his
cloaking device Powers down and so
that's when the field is basically even
now right he says because this is the
end of a long long trail one that has
spanned time and distance and in these
final moments of the hunt he wants to be
seen he wants us to face each other to
recognize each other as predator and
prey when he rips out my spawn so that's
when the HonorBound element really
begins to come into play but there is
kind of a c out here that we'll talk
about here in a second because yes
predators are HonorBound and yes
Predators really fight more for the hunt
and the enjoyment of the sport and so on
and so forth but there is something
going on here that Wolverine is picking
up on and it's not spoken it's not
something that he sees and it's really
kind of us delving more into what we
could argue to be like interpretation
and halfhazard guessing but I have a
feeling that I'm 100% right here right
he says I don't know how long I've been
hanging from this Cliff Maybe 10 minutes
maybe an hour long enough that the
healing factor is kicking in blood gums
up nerves fuse torn muscles seal I
needed a be to recover because more pain
is waiting for me out there below is a
fall of 200 ft or so above me somewhere
is the hunter who comes from the Stars
he's stubborn coming at me all these
years but I'm patient too we've gone
head-to-head enough times that I'm going
to trust my instincts he's moving on
looking for me elsewhere hopefully and
then of course that's when he realizes
that's not what's happening that the
Predator knew he was down there maybe it
was a sense of smell maybe it was his
ability to hear maybe it was the fact
that looking down in the riverbed below
he didn't see any heat signatures so
Wolverine had to have simply been
holding on to the cliffs just logical
deduction but whatever it is man he
starts throwing weapons at
Wolverine and Wolverine's like crap
right so he's just literally bobbing and
weaving so Wolverine at this point just
plunges down into the water and at that
point the Predator follows him directly
down in there because the only thing
that really matters to the Predator when
it comes to water is the effect that it
has on his cloaking device but if at
this point the cloaking device doesn't
matter because he wants this fight to be
the final fight and he wants to be seen
by wolver rain right he doesn't want to
skull in the shadows he wants wolver
rain to see the face that kills him then
the cloaking device doesn't matter at
all and so even wolver rain right kind
of coming to comments he says I'm
trapped under two tons of rubble at the
bottom of a river and he thinks he's got
me but I know something he doesn't
hunting is Elemental you study dirt for
tracks and Sport you stay downwind you
note what's growing or hatching or
breeding and he says you know where to
find water and shelter it's not about
the gear you never come across those
Trophy Hunters who Dro 20 grand to kill
a Grizzly or a lion with their laser
sights and multi-caliber sniper rifles
you know they don't really know what
they're doing and he says the fancier
the tech the cockier you get and the
more detached you are from the musk and
the bloodbeat of the thing you want dead
and this is where the observation comes
in because he says in the right hands
the same job could be done with a simple
blade or three and so that's when
Wolverine really starts to use these
things to his advantage and that's where
contextually it looks like he's just now
figured out about the idea of the
Predator using heat signatures to track
him again it's contextual not really a
definitive answer but he basically cuts
through himself in order to get himself
free right he knows he'll heal but it's
like a feral animal right just like
doing whatever it has to do to get free
from the trap that it's in I lured him
back to the place where it would just be
the two of us the river where I would
make my last stand the good mud waited
for us here a dog can smell 100,000
times better than a human I don't know
if that's true or not bees can see
ultraviolet light and birds can sense
magnetic fields I'd observe the Predator
long enough to know he registered Heat
Signature the mud was my primitive
version of a cloaking device and that's
when the Trap comes in because as the
Predator makes his way out of the water
he sees in what looks like this pile of
mud an eyeball staring at it just enough
of a heat signature for him to make out
the shape of the object that he's
looking at to see the eye there put two
and two together and say this guy's
hiding in mud and this guy's watching me
but when he gets there it's only just an
eyeball wolver removed his own eye and
put it in mud in order to lure the
Predator it's pretty genius now this is
where I talk about the unspoken thing
that Wolverine had realized he says when
I leaped down on him it was with the
gravity of a 100 Years of War I ad ired
him as much as I hated him I imagine the
feeling was Mutual he cooked me with a
few thousand volts and whipped out what
looked like a ceremonial dagger to
finish the job now here's the thing a
predator would not just arbitrarily leap
into that environment and then just
attack a thing instead because they're
intelligent because Wolverine had built
traps and things like that it would go
in expecting some kind of trap as
primitive as they may be it would expect
them none thess and so it would observe
all the surroundings and then figure out
that Wolverine was hiding in a tree like
that what's really unspoken here is that
over the time that they have been
fighting this is no longer like it was
in the first issue which is the Predator
stumbling across this guy who looks like
he'd be a really cool enemy to track and
fight and then like he'll kill him and
then he'll take his head and like
that'll be his trophy and that'll be it
instead now it had become a vendetta
that the the Predator was so single
mindedly focused on finding Wolverine
that he almost reacted to it with so
much emotion the way that a human would
right like it's that kind of thing and
being so single-minded means it would
make mistakes it would do things that it
wasn't necessarily supposed to do an
example of this is not observing all its
surroundings because if it had it would
have seen wol rain up there in the tree
and so wolver rain coming down here
because it's not like he's covered in
mud right I mean it'd be different if he
had jumped down from the tree covered in
mud that would have been a dead giveaway
there's no mud on him it's just him
hiding in a tree hoping that the
Predator would be so single focused that
he wouldn't notice him and that's
exactly what happens right he blasts
wolver rain with a boatload of
electricity and then pulls out the
ceremonial dagger and that's usually
kind of the indicator in any fight that
a predator has that okay one this is the
final fight and two this is how we
actually solve this on a personal level
the funny thing here though is that as
many of you guys expected the Predator
is not going to be able to kill wolver
rain it never could one because of
wolver rain's healing factor and two
because of his adamantium there's no
material that the Predators have that
would be able to cut through true
adamantium this bondage to Wolverine
skeleton sever his spinal column from
the rest of his body or even just his
head and call it a day that was never
going to happen and then any damage that
the Predator is able to inflict on
wolver rain his healing factor is going
to take care of the rest you show up
with some adamantium claws this game was
over before it even started and so
literally within this fan of three
panels wolver rain's just like boom boom
boom done and like the Predator's just
like okay right like it realizes there's
no conceivable way for it to win and so
what it does here right like you have
this really really cool monologue from
Wolverine he says I let him make a
sheath of me we would end this eye to
eye tasting the blood in each other's
breath for a fatal moment we were one
and the same I thought that was the end
but he refused to die on my terms I
didn't recognize the numbers but I knew
a countdown when I saw one right the
self-destruct weapon right the bomb that
the Predators use he was going to get
that trophy even if he claimed it in his
grave but here's the thing about desire
once you get what you want you realize
that wanting was the real pleasure so in
those final bloody seconds when the hunt
finally ended I hope he felt a century
of disappointment slam into his heart
and so literally it was a predator
realizing there's no real Victory to be
had here there was no way he could
actually kill wolver rain and you knew
that and I knew that and Marvel knew
that when they were writing it but it is
still cool to see man sometimes it's not
about the destination it really is about
the journey and this is one of those
examples and so once that happens wolver
rain just kind of emerges from the rebel
with this healing Factor kicked in he
takes the ceremonial Dagger of the
predator and then keeps it for itself so
I will say I mean sure the story ended
exactly the way we thought it would but
a story like this really isn't so much
about the end result it's not really
about the destination it really is about
the journey and it was amazing so with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end if you need to get
caught up on the entirety of Wolverine
and Predator make sure you guys click
this link to the playlist and I will
catch you all later peace